good morning everyone welcome to the
workshop and we'll get started in just a
moment we'll give it a few more minutes
for everyone to join in so please feel
free to share in the chat where you're
joining us from today a nice Mexico
I see mati from Germany so I'm actually
calling in from sunny and cold Virginia
where also some of you from
well those who just joined in just what
we wait for everyone to join the
workshop or get gonna give it a couple
more minutes so please feel free to
share in the chat where you're joining
us from today on it--so we have two from
Germany well part of Germany Daniela
not interesting north rhine-westphalia
interesting anyone else would love to
hear where you're calling in from today
okay so I think we can go ahead and get
started
welcome again to all of you thank you
for joining us on this Saturday I know
there are many other things that you
could have been doing this weekend but
but yeah definitely this is a topic that
I'm very very passionate about and so
I'm really glad that you are here you're
interested and so I see a diet from
Nigeria welcome we have a very diverse
group here very exciting so let's go
ahead and get started so web met Renee
today is about setting up for career
success using goal-setting and visioning
and so just a little bit about me so I'm
a passionate career coach whose work has
been centered around getting my clients
to determine what they're most
passionate about
defining or redefining their life and
creating a feeling and purpose driven
career and going after those seemingly
impossible dreams so just a little bit
about myself and kind of what brought me
to Udacity really this is this has been
a passion of mine for so very long
I was in a child for many many many
years in HR and recruitment and about
four or five years ago I decided to
transition into full-time recruitment
because I really not remember into
coaching from recruitment because I
wanted to make sure that I saw so many
people you know not living up to to to
where they
wanted to be you or to their biggest
dreams and so really I had to take that
myself because I was miserable what I
was doing and it no longer served me and
so in that journey and really everything
that I learned that is what really
created my passion to become a career
coach and also do career coaching life
coaching in a huge interest I don't
coach in holistic health and wellness
I have lived in several continents I
spent a lot of time in the Middle East
Africa and Europe and now I'm based in
the u.s. in Virginia Northern Virginia
right outside of DC so today's agenda
will be defining what goal-setting is
and visioning I know a lot of you know
what that is but then obviously because
your name what SMART goal setting looks
like and how they work together in this
energy that they bring when they're
brought together and then pretty much
how you can get started on some of your
goals and keeping progress addressing
some of the roadblocks that you'll come
across and then obviously we'll do an
exercise around goal setting and then
we'll have a Q&A any questions you have
any questions so far
any questions comments okay great so
we'll keep going so we'll start with a
question to you all and I would love for
all of you to chime in of a muted you
also either you can speak up or you can
type in your response in the group chat
but I'd love to hear from each of you
what has been your biggest challenge
when it comes to setting goals and
following through are you great at it is
it something that you do all the time
and you follow through is it something
that you're so so
beginning of every year you'll set goals
with steam and then kind of lose steam
as the year goes along or never look at
them again or you just never set goals
and have no experience in goal-setting
so either respond 1 2 or 3 um as it
relates to you and either you can
respond in the chat of the muta-do okay
so let's see a lot of choose 2 2 1 2
okay so looks like most of us I either
so-so or never set goals or no
experience um it's definitely a work in
progress for all of us we have one one
which is great so I would love to hear
what you'll get out of this call
hopefully you're looking to get your
goals even stronger but that's amazing
so yeah small goals definitely most of
us are so so and you know some are never
but this is hopefully gonna change by
the end of this call so on to the next
one visioning is a powerful exercise
that helps you hone in to what you
really want it helps you kind of break
out of the traditional goal setting
where okay you sit down and it's really
boring and no one likes to do it
visioning is where you bring in your
imagination remember back when your
child and you imagine your life you know
you could create in your mind you know
what you want it to be like you know you
wanted to do this what you wanted to do
that whatever it was it was very easy to
creatively to picture it um so this is
what visioning is it's coming back to
really using your imagination - what
would it look like if my career look
like this or if my life look like this
so today you are here
you're either a student or you are a
professional who wants to transition
into a new career how do you make that
transition from what you are not today
into something that you want to become
great at right how do you make that it's
by visioning what would you like to look
like if you were living out your dreams
right what would your life look like and
when you're just sitting there and going
back to the childlike imagination where
there you don't have anything holding
you there's no financial constraints
there's no time constraints there is no
family constraints and mostly actually
our minds are what keep us from really
getting to our goals most of the times
we think of something vehicle here's
something big and what I I want to do
that and that our mind just comes in and
shuts us down nope you can do that no no
no you'll never make it you're not good
enough you don't have enough education
you can not create a public speaking
your language skills on great you know
we really really really our biggest
critic and our biggest enemy sometimes
or goals and to fissioning can be our
own minds so when we go into the
imagination we kind of bypass that
critical mind and we're just like it's a
it's it's a game it's an exercise that
we're doing it's not something that's
real you know and so play around with
that you know get in the state of
creation get in a state where the
possibilities are endless so that is
what visioning means to me okay and and
it has had so many successful uses I'll
give you an example I'm not sure if most
of you know Michael Phelps but he was a
swimmer that went to winning many many
many gold medals he went from no one
knowing him to one year swiping off
almost all the Swimming gold medals that
were there for swimming in the Olympics
several years ago
and when he when you hear his story you
know he he learned from his coach
visioning and I love love love how how
passionately he speaks about it because
his coach made him really what first he
came up with goals right this is what I
want to do I want to break every
swimming record what does it mean to
bring that to break that to me record
its by beating each and every this
particular time right so what would it
take to beat this time is I need to do
every lap in this much time right and
then you know bring it to completion and
that's how I break the records and so
literally every single morning and every
single night he sat there and in his
mind he saw himself swimming each of
those laps getting to the other end in
the amount of time that he did swimming
back and he would do that over and over
and over again like you literally do it
in however much time you need to do it
him he practiced it in his mind day in
and day out every single day until the
Olympics came and sure enough when on
the Olympics came he went ahead and
broke all those records so a lot of time
visioning is what gets us so we have
goals but visioning also creates a
picture of what it would look like in
our minds and our minds of powerful
creators because our bodies follow our
minds we do what we need not much so
this is the power of visioning and this
is how this is what can help take your
goals to the next level so let's go to
the next slide so what are smarter goal
so a lot of you know goal-setting you
know you know okay you write down your
goals you put timelines around them but
some of you may have heard of SMART
goals
I go by even smarter goals so what is a
goal and what is a solid-gold so it
needs to be specific so details are
important so saying I want to be in a
data scientist role is not specific
enough
specific is I want to be in a
science fall within the next three years
where I am within this company where
have these kind of responsibilities
where I have this many direct reports
get as specific as you can on your goals
because again when you're visioning them
you need to create them so again coming
back to the specifics you need to be as
specific as you can because it's in the
specificity that you can make them
measurable so you're not able to
quantify progress without being very
very specific so it's enough to have a
big goal but you definitely need to
chunk down and get it as specific as
possible
then that brings us to the next which is
measurable you need to be able to
quantify progress so I want to lose a
hundred pounds in the next I don't know
three months right if I say I want to
lose a hundred pounds it could be the
next ten months it could be in the next
three years or it could be in the next
ten years or I could say I want to lose
weight how much weight do you want to
lose you know so if I haven't put a
specific measurable quality to my goal
then it becomes very difficult a goal
because you cannot quantify your
progress then it needs to be achievable
and this is a tricky tricky one because
yes it should be achievable but this
should not hold you back from really
really visioning up and creating
something that you cannot see how you
get there today
so envisioning I say you go all out you
can be as irrational as possible
but when you come to actually writing
your goals and try to make sure that
they are as achievable as you can and
what I mean by this is for example I
have it as a goal that I want to run a
marathon okay it's not achievable for me
to say that I am going to run a marathon
in one month if I have not seen at all
if I am been sitting on the couch I have
not seen the inside of a gym and
years and there's no way that I can run
a madman in a month you know I could
probably do it in eight months or you
know take a train but if I've been
already training and and it's just a
matter of okay I need to get it done
then yes it's achievable
it's achievable within one month so
that's where you need to ensure that you
goes achievable then that they're
relevant or relatable to you so again
they're relevant to your life you know
they are not for someone else and they
are like for example it's you're setting
a goal this this is very much career
oriented you know so it's relevant to
your career as it is as it stands today
oh it's relevant to life as it stands
today not just someone else's then
obviously that it's time-based so it
should always have a time assigned each
age so whether it's you know one year
with a six months whether it's five
years but there should always be time so
most goals almost the times you see this
you see that they're called SMART goals
and you see on the right the diagram
specific measurable attainable relevant
and time-based so I'd like to add two
more letters to this which is evaluate
and reward which makes them even smarter
goals so it's a lot of us especially at
the beginning of the year we write all
these goals we're really excited we'll
get right ready to get them done and
then we never close that book so goals
and need to be evaluated regularly and
you need to be looking at them every day
every month
checking your milestones seeing what
you've done and correcting you know
sometimes we create goals and then
realized huh you know that is something
that you did so making sure that you are
evaluating regularly as well as
rewarding yourself so having milestones
you know so back to the weight goal I
need to lose a hundred pounds but then
break it down
I need to lose 100 pounds within a year
I want to lose maybe 10 pounds or
whatever every month so every time so
that would be a milestone right and if
every month you check whether you've
been able to lose a 10 pounds if you
have then you come up with a reward
system hopefully it's not to go on any
ice cream but but definitely come up
coming up with a reward system that is a
motivation well one for you to continue
with the goals and choose for you to
really yeah to think yourself and to
think your body you have to think
whatever else for achieving that so so
I'd love to add evaluate and reward on
to my goal setting and that just makes
them even SMART goals so I'm gonna take
a pause here to see there any questions
again I will unmute you all or you are
free to type into the chat box but just
let me know if you have any questions I
can answer before we move forward on
SMART goals okay great all right my
little challenge accepted rules actually
I think you completed the measurable
aspect you speak a woman honor it's not
so clear okay so I said the thing is
that within me I actually know what I
want okay I want to be a scientist what
the specifics now is currently my my
current job what I do is just
applications of heart rate issues
concerns and I cover for them around
just by busting into the data science
role and my plans immediately okay for
hospice like this means I work on three
projects they want success target for
myself now but I say okay number of
costuming I many days order I say
by the end of amounts are bound to be
also I'm taking maybe five courses like
I don't that's my challenge actually
like up
that's the group I dunno call most times
and I start like this I think a few
costigan outside Wow okay feel I already
know a little bit and I try I try to
leave my hands or some other projects
and I'm like like I never knew anything
at all so I really challenge okay so and
what I would do in this case is what is
the go back to the purpose of you taking
the forces what is the purpose for you
taking the forces the major purposes I
want through the importance of okay I
don't to be able to show up before Tina
immediate Sciences when it comes to data
I can do it because these are analyzed
advice okay so just like to confirm that
I've heard you correctly you want to be
able to tell people that you are a data
scientist and not just an analyst
correct well of course not just tell
people also have aquarium bypass okay
okay great so then your goal should be
around what the purpose of you taking
the courses is so I want to be a data
scientist by this day working for this
company you know and whatever else that
you need to do to get there because the
courses are just the actionable steps
for you to get to your goal does that
make sense yeah so so the steps
themselves don't need to be the goal so
if you need you might need five courses
you might need 10 courses but that's
something that you figure out as you go
along right
but the goal of large is for you to be
able to transition to become a big
scientist right so what do I need to
become a data scientist I need to take
this many courses I need to do this I
need to be an experience you know there
are many things that fall under that so
but in order for you to set a goal then
it should be around you becoming a data
scientist and you can set some goals
related to that and put timelines around
it but the key goal would be the you
know the purpose for you doing the
courses are you getting the experience
etc etc so focus on what the purpose of
some of the samples is I think that will
help make things a little bit easier for
you
okay does that make sense yeah okay okay
great
and then I see a question from one um
who says do steps milestones need to be
in the smart format as well
definitely that's where time base should
be it's very very very much a part of
the smart because that's where the time
comes in that's how you evaluate your
progress so yeah you'll have the bigger
mind stone of where you want like for
example back to my way I want to have
lost 100 pounds by the end of the year
so that's the big amount right is by the
end of you know 50 20 I want to have
lost 100 pounds but then how do I get
there so break it up within two months
your next question is what do we have to
do so we don't go to the extreme of
having a ton of smart goals or a lot of
milestones again this is a very personal
question it all depends on how on who
you are and having work on some people
can work with 500 goals and get through
all of them as long as you're able to do
all of these things each one you're able
to evaluate your progress regularly with
them but it's all about being realistic
right if I know I want to train for
again going after marathon and I have
three kids and I have a wife and I have
a very demanding career and training for
that would be three hours of exercise a
day is that really smart no it's not and
it's not realistic for my life so go
back to the definitions of each of the
SMART goals it will and if your goal
that you're working to is not smart it
works really different through each of
the different words then it will become
very clear to you that that's a goal
that you should make thankfully is it or
become more realistic about I hope that
answers your question one yes it does
Thanks very good
any other questions
okay great and we'll have a lot more but
you needed to ask so thank you for the
great question so far my age name so
next we have we're gonna bring them
together okay so it's one thing to those
in our minds most of us know what we
want to be working towards most of us
know what we want but it's so important
to write them on paper okay
this can be the single most factor
between success and failure for gold
write them down make sure that that's
the next phase that's the next step in
creation is getting them out of your
head and on paper so it's so so so
important to write them down and then
we've talked about envisioning them so
it's not only enough to write them down
they're really envisioned so we were
just talking I believe it was a Guyot
who wanted to become a data scientist so
envisioning what would a day in my life
look like but for example again I'm just
putting this for you but if I were to
become a data scientist in the next five
years what would my day look like
right I would wake up in the morning
excited because this is something that
I've been wanting for a long time so I'm
passionate I would go to work this is
what my work look like this is what my
office with it like this is what my boss
if I have direct reports this is what I
would be doing throughout the game this
is the amount of time out spent at work
literally thinking through that in your
mind and keep running through until you
have the perfect vision of what that
would look like on your day as a data
scientist or whatever else your goal is
but really write it down one and then
envision it and envisioning you know
it's a two-part you know one is using
your imagination to kind of come up with
a list then creating goals from that
list and then once you have the goals
envisioning what those goals will look
like once they come to you you're
creating in your mind
and once created in your mind it will
come to be if that you they become a
fundamental in your life so you're
looking at him everyday you're running
through you know like my Phelps did you
know he ran through this every single
night before he went to bed every
morning first thing you thought about it
every night the last thing the rent room
is mind and not only did he just think
about it but he vision would look like
for him to its mind over and over and
over and literally he created it so that
that wasn't my next statement every
great thing was created in the mind and
bind to existence by sticking to the big
picture vision no matter what the
obstacles and in your day-to-day life
you always have people who don't believe
in you always have forces better to
difficult you know there'll always be
things that and roadblocks that will
keep you from getting to your goals but
as long as you keep coming back to your
big picture and using the tools of
visioning using the tools of constantly
evaluating and re-evaluating the goal
say for example when you write them down
it shouldn't be written in a book and
put away you know you should have the
journal of you know like to a little
success Journal this is where you write
your goals you write all your dreams you
write everything that you're working
towards and then you look at this every
single day if you have to cut out that
piece of paper and put it to somewhere
where by your bedside so that way you
really need every night before you go to
sleep or you know when you wake up the
next day you know you have it in your
calendar to constantly evaluate your
goals how am i doing you know most of us
in our jobs have performance appraisals
with our bosses that the that tell us
okay this is what you've done this past
year this is the progress you've made
there's our areas for improvement these
are things they should be doing with
your goals as well
how have I done congratulate yourself
when you're doing great wherever you're
struggling see what you can do to kind
of mitigate some of those struggles and
then also having accountability it is so
important not only and I feel like one
of the things that holds us back from
even making goals it's just a fact of oh
my gosh we might feel like what if I
completely
I'm just not good at it or I you know I
don't do well and so one thing is just
all this is better just not to do it oh
it just never comes on farm on and/or
then we get it on paper and then no one
knows about it so then there's no
failure associated with it but make
yourself accountable find someone who
will hold you accountable to your goals
that you trust you know it could be even
social media you know put it out there
that hey I'm asking all of you to help
me to stay accountable to my goals I
will report back to you every whatever
one week three weeks one month whatever
works for you but find a way to pull if
it's really a goal that you want to
accomplish you need to find a way to
make yourself accountable so found an
accountability find a mentor you know
use social media whatever it is get it
out of your head get it on paper get it
out there and that's the only way that
you'll be able to stick with it as we
know most goals fail most people who
start with New Year's resolutions which
are pretty much goals by the end of
January are out of the window you know
wearing what mid February and most
people have already just completely not
done anything so you want you do not
want to be part of that majority and
part of what we're doing today is to
making sure that one you're setting so
that goes into your being successful
okay okay so I would love to hear some
of your thoughts where some of you might
have done this
unintentionally you know it may be some
of you have experience with vision
combining visioning and goal-setting
some of you might be hearing it for the
first time but just think back through
your life I remember when I really got
into both setting and visioning and you
know realizing the power of creation
that we have I remember thinking back to
when I was a child and so much of what I
imagined and I wanted to be a part of my
life then and I used to sit and imagine
day in and out and sometimes I didn't
talk about it to my friend I ended up
creating later on in my life and so and
at the
I didn't know this is what I was doing
you know like I loved I loved enough to
travel I remember I used to look at
photo albums of my parents and they had
traveled all through Europe and they had
all these pictures and I and I just
loved it and I literally would imagine
myself in these places and sometimes I'd
even tell my friends you know in my
childlike imagination I've been here to
Paris women too nice and I've been here
and I could really see myself being in
those places and how I felt and and that
really fueled my passion travel and by
the time I was before I was even 20 I
had been to most of the places in Europe
that my parents had been I didn't
realize essential after the fact but
really it's it's so so powerful in
directing our lives so I'd love to hear
from some of you if any of you have used
visioning and just think back on your
life in your childhood and the things
used to imagine and and let you know
share with us either again you can share
of inuvik you all or you can share the
chat and the group chat about maybe some
goals it doesn't matter how big or small
they don't have to be clearly related
where you have done this we've done this
intentionally or unintentionally where
you've combined visioning and
goal-setting so I see a response from
you one so I heard a great saying one
time that said bring the idea from your
mind down to your heart they have to be
in sync what happens to me a lot is I
set a goal and passionate about do all
the steps then something else comes into
mind and now I want that and not work I
already started okay well that's a very
very valid question but then that brings
me to the fact of how committed way you
to the first idea was it something that
you really really worked through or is
it something that it was just kind of
huh let me go down this path and see
where it takes me
you know so exploration is very very
different and that's fine too you know
sometimes you don't really know what we
want and that's with
so again really coming to goal should be
some it should be you know this would be
something that in the long term you owe
in the short term it's something that
you really really want you steamed
around it you know it's what makes you
want to jump out of bed and you cannot
see yourself doing anything else those
are really really should be the driver
around those goals but again you can put
goals around exploration and that's a
different thing you know you're
exploring different passions that's one
thing but don't let that get you down as
all I'm not meeting goals because again
it's more exploration of you figuring
out what it is that you want but then
when you do figure this is for sure what
I want then you commit to it and you
stick it out and maybe again setting
those milestones and checking them off
as you're going along will help you get
to the end of the goal or maybe even
coming up with shorter term goals that
are more achievable and as you're
achieving those they help you get okay
so thank you for your question one
because anyone else have a sharing on
how they might have done this in their
past successfully or even if it's been
unintentionally just think back to your
childhood think about when you have that
all overactive imagination and create
anything in your mind I'd love to get
Lisa sharing from one of you okay great
we have a story from monkey so when I
was 14 I was in summer camp where we
needed to write down who would like to
be as adults everything I wrote down I
could accomplish so power of visioning
works I do this continuously I love that
and truly truly truly and it is so so
powerful and we the more you do this the
more you realize how much of a role
our Creator you know a lot of times we
give our power to other people to our
bosses to our situations but really it
we have so much power in creating in our
lives and it all envisioning country
envisioning and goals that income really
we really change your life it was done
right you can make a point to make very
very solar goals
and care that with visioning you can
almost get to anything and you look at
anyone who's that you achieved anything
great you know from the Walt Disney well
Disney was was homeless you know and he
refused to be shaken from what his goals
were for the vision that he had for
Disney he had no idea how video yeah but
he knew in his mind what he wanted to
accomplish and he was not willing to to
take less you know his idea for Mickey
Mouse was actually when he was you know
digging through the trash and looking
for something to eat and a little mouse
runs by him and he's also trying to get
what he was trying to get and that's
what that was his idea for Mickey Mouse
so again goal-setting and visioning is
so so powerful and if you hear every
great person's story this was a part of
their this was a part of their story so
how do you get started the key would be
taking inventory where are you
versus where do you want to be so this
is your career like today where are you
you know I'm here I just graduated I
don't have any experience or I have lots
of experience but I want to transition
or you know I'm not happy in this
company and I want to be in a different
company or I've been working in for
someone else for too many years and I
want to break off on my own and start my
own business where are you today and
where do you want to be then start now
that's the only way to to get started
you know our minds again like like for
things to remain the same right even if
it's painfully so so the key is starting
now start where you are start today I
remember one of the things is when I
transition from corporate I
I loved love you know I love coaching I
was so passionate about it yes this is
what drives me but then I was so
attached to you know I was an expert you
know I've been working in HR and talent
acquisition and recruitment for 15 years
you know direct to level you know people
came to me for advice you know why I've
had all the education that had
everything to where no one question you
know my skills or my abilities and then
now when I started coaching where a lot
of you know my HR skills and all that I
can use in coaching it still was okay
I'm starting from scratch right so how
do I get started so I took several
courses books but I remember I could not
get myself to start and one of the last
course of the night trip I'll never
forget the instructors said you walk out
of this door and you start becoming a
coach to get it because you will never
be ready in your mind you will never be
ready you know there's always this why
you take this other course I need you do
this my nature to that before you're
ready to start going after your goals
you have to bypass that what can you
start today and literally put yourself
out there and just start you know don't
even give it thought because as soon as
you give it thought your mind will come
in and say no cut it off so really start
today we're in this this is great that
all of you have shown up today so I
would say after this fall wherever it is
that you've been stuck wherever it is
that you in regards to your career or
any of you can apply these to any area
of your life start now start today then
in addition to getting started then you
always have to keep progress
so again accountability I talked about
that before making sure that you have a
system for accountability for your goals
whether it's having someone new families
having a friend who's actually gonna see
you through media whatever it is we all
have different personalities and
different accountability mechanisms so
making sure that you have
countable then reassessing you know
sometimes we create goals that don't
later that we realize don't align with
the direction or no longer aligned with
what we want so reassessing is this
timeline reasonable is this goal
reasonable with what I want to
accomplish in my life right so making
sure that you constantly assessing and
making adjustments as needed because
again we need to keep those goals as
realistic as possible then all you see
Muslims we've talked about this so
breaking them down so how do you climb
them out you know people clown every
silly crime you know different mountains
and when you think about getting to the
top it's if your mind will shut down
because it's overwhelming right but how
do you get to the top with each and
every step thing if you know when you're
climbing the mountain you go through
different Basecamp so you go to the
first base camp then you get to the
second then you get to the third then
you get to the fourth and eventually
each and every step that you took gets
you to the top but it can be very
overwhelming thinking about just getting
to the top like forget about it so again
creating those smaller milestones that
you can work through that you can reward
yourself as you're getting there
that you can use to see to check your
progress making sure that you keeping up
with those milestones okay so next are
funding box and we've talked about some
of them already but there are obviously
many many many stumbling blocks to goals
one is setting unrealistic
so again when it comes to imagination
you want to imagine the world you want
to imagine the planet you and imagine
the galaxy you know you want to put
whatever it is that you can into the
imagination but when you set goals you
want to make them realistic going back
to the marathon I cannot run a marathon
in one month unless I've been training
prior you know so again making sure that
when it comes down to actually working
on your goals that they are listed so
focusing on two key areas so today with
specifically speaking about career goals
right
but I can have a career goal where I
want to be CEO in the next five years
but yeah I have two young children at
home a six-month-old in the 1-yard yes
it can be done but how will that affect
my family life you know how will that
affect other areas of my life
so always thinking and reevaluating how
any of your goals affect the bigger
picture right and you should have goals
for every of them major areas in life so
obviously eventually you have your
family life you have your career you
have you know your personal development
and each of these buckets should be in
balance and if I have a goal in my
career like that is gonna greatly affect
a goal in my in my home life one it's
not likely to be successful and then two
it's probably not a very good goal to
have so again really looking at the big
picture and focusing on every area of
your life whilst you're another big one
and this came in as actually one of the
questions of is either unknown over
estimating completion time so a lot of
times we and actually it's more under
estimating minoo we're estimating all
like oh yeah I can do that I can easily
do that in this amount of time and then
in a month you haven't even looked at it
you haven't started get discouraged and
that whole just completely it's done you
never you know you you give up on it
because you feel like you've failed
right so most of the times this comes
from under estimating completion time so
really thinking about what's reasonable
depending on your life and your schedule
you know right now I'm enrolled in
school I'm doing my bachelor's my thesis
is due I'm doing that how realistic is
it to add another huge goal there you
know so making sure that you're really
sitting with your schedule your family
life your time commitments and then
figuring out a vocation time that is
comfortable for you and add a little bit
of a buffer as well understanding that
life happens and things happen but then
you don't want to also overestimate
you know because then you lose steam
over time and then it will be back you
won't have a little bit of pressure that
you need in order to
okay and then another thing is setting
tasks rather than gold
so again tasks a very different and
tasks can go into helping us reach our
goals but they are very different than
the goals themselves and then lack of
clarity this is a big one you know and
every time I go into a coaching session
with any of my client to students the
first thing you know it it's so clear to
me the direction of their careers
thinking based on the level of clarity
that they have you know so the level of
knowing no and I get this all the time
most of my career coaching clients will
come to me and they're having issues
closing you know they'll tell me and
they're really good they have the
backgrounds have the experience they
have everything and they know the job
and you're like I don't understand why
I've gone through all these interviews I
make it to the last round but I cannot
close and get the job why and it always
comes back to a lack of clarity they
weren't sure whether this is something
that they really wanted or they were you
know there another career crossroads so
there was a lack of clarity in their
minds or stored a wanted and that also
comes as a Mac of you know I don't clear
direction your own lies I like to give
the GPS example when I put in an address
in my GPS right the more detail that can
get the easier it is for me to get to
where I'm going right I have the option
of putting in the state right so I'm
putting the state of Virginia yeah I
will get me to the state of Virginia but
then what right then I can put in the
state you know within Virginia I can put
you know Arlington Virginia
right so then it will get me to
Arlington but Arlington is big you know
I want to get to some address so again
this is gold the more specific you can
get with gold the more likely you can
get to exactly where you want to be so I
can get to Arlington but Arlington is
big where do I really want to get it get
you with in Arlington right and that's
where you want to go you want to get to
the end of your goal right so if I put
an address you see I put in the building
number I put in their apartment number
then you know that GPS will get me
exactly there
and that is the clarity that you need to
have in your goals because the more
clearer your goals are the more likely
you are to get there okay and then also
using failure as a teacher sometimes
we'll have goals that will not come to
me right and rather than just bury that
and say oh yeah I knew I wouldn't do it
you know you Zack look at it what could
I have done better what could I have
done different how do I walk away
stronger because of this you know
sometimes Thomas Edison failed a
thousand times before the light finally
worked you know but what he didn't take
his failure as his light towards his his
goal wasn't good enough you know he took
it out okay that wasn't the way to do it
there must be another way and there must
be another way and there must be another
way until he got to where he wanted to
go
so using failure as your teacher okay so
those are some of the stumbling blocks I
have and I'd love to hear some of your
thoughts on any setbacks of stumbling
blocks that you've had in achieving your
goals in the past or that you might be
facing currently I would love to hear
what you'd have to share and feel free
to either speak up or you can share in
the chat just think back to you know any
setbacks you've experienced that we've
kind of talked about maybe that you can
add into the list that I had doing the
others are you currently facing but I'd
love to hear some around onto this you
experienced the wrong goal setting
I have a question one so I'm going to go
ahead and read it out to you all so the
more detailed I have my goal the harder
it gets support zone right now I want to
change jobs and country it's possible
but would like to change the job
I love in a country I want to mix it
harder my major stumbling block is lack
of discipline I give myself various
excuses but I think overcoming that now
well it's very very very good and again
this is part of the exercises really
honestly looking at what are some of
what holds you back from reaching your
goals you know you said a major
stumbling block is that discipline that
happens for a lot of us you know we're
you know and it's always easy to just
say no I can't do it and this is where
accountability really comes into play
where you have to have people utilize
people or tools to keep you accountable
whether it's using the calendar whether
it's using apps whether it's talking to
people whether it's using social media
with A to Z family whether it's signing
up to like for example when I really
need to get back to number tune again
and make sure that I need a pain for
something that requires me to show up
everyday or if it's a trainer that will
be hey where are you show up you know
until I make it a way of life but really
bill and discipline is if it's a muscle
it just needs to be built you know in
each time that you're able to overcome
those excuses and walk around it then
you've built it just a little bit more
in just a little bit mine just a little
bit more then when you start achieving
your goals it becomes so much easier to
do it so thank you guys that so coming
back to your question one so obviously
the more detail to my goal that hardly
gets so again this comes back to making
sure that you have realistic goals so
sometimes you can say yes I want to
change a job in country a stop but have
you really looked at how you know the
legalities around it today you know
these some research that goes around
making reasonable goals right so making
sure that yeah you go you want it to be
detailed and specific but ok if I want
to be within this country by this time
but the legalities we're gonna allow
that then then that becomes a difficult
you know a goal that's set up to fail so
again making sure that your goals and
realistic and that are actually
researched and okay alright really
appreciate your sharing Zwan any daya
so we'll come up to an exercise where I
love to you to take a few minutes where
I hope all of you have a piece of paper
and pen okay
and what I would like to for you to do
is imagine that your little child right
or you know when you were growing up
when you still believe in Santa set to
ask you or you are writing a letter to
Santa saying everything that you want
remember that state of mind they were in
that you were like I want five bike
someone this and I want that and there
was nothing that held you back from
asking for whatever it was that you
wanted that's the state of mind that I
want you to go into as we do this
exercise and it would be very short
because I know we're coming up to our
hour but I really want to get you in a
state of mind from absolute and complete
expectation with no limits okay so what
I want you to do is for the next four
minutes now that you know what to start
I want you to write as fast as you can
in a
right quickly as you can do not stop
writing you know and just right what do
you like to be what you'd want to be
doing what you'd like to become many
skills and the abilities and traits
anything you'd like to accomplish career
or otherwise again goal-setting is goal
setting it doesn't matter what area of
your life I don't focus on career today
but it's easier for you to do it for
another aspect of your life feel free to
do it but I want you to write as fast as
you can do not stop writing you know you
need to abbreviate only you need to
understand that's fine but for the next
four minutes I want you to write as fast
as you can you know just what some of
your goals would be but again coming
from a space of creation I can be
anything I can do anything I can get
better one so just write write write
write write so I'd like for you to start
if you can go ahead and start now okay
and I'll let you know when to stop again
you know just keep writing would like
doing what you'd like to go what you
think accomplish what are some skills
what if some abilities that you want to
give me what have some accomplishments
that you just see just keep writing
I'm so praying just as fast as you can
whatever you can think about any area of
your life anything regular to accomplish
what would you write your works on the
fight again no limits
absent a space of absolute expectation
you can have whatever it is that you
want what do you want you have two more
minutes so keep on writing you're
running as fast as you can do not stop
writing think about what's important to
you think about all those things that
you've done tonight that you still dream
about haven't you know all those things
that are important to you than die
important to your life from the story
that you'd like to be able to tell one
day once you look back into your life
think about what you've been able to
accomplish
okay so we're coming to the last minute
so just start winding down and again I'm
still keep writing keep reading okay so
so I'd like you to put your pen down now
and see if you can quickly go through
this okay and put some timelines around
each of the key areas or any of the
major goals that you've written so I'd
like for you to put just the one beside
anything that you want to have completed
or accomplished than one year or less I
like to put a three around anything that
you'd like to have done within the next
three years or less a five four five
years or less or a ten for ten years or
less and if you have anything greater
than that for twenty you know for
example for 20 you come to 20 but I'd
like you to put either one three five or
ten for each of the items that you jot
it down and I'll just give you about 30
seconds
I know we don't have a lot of time left
so this is what I'm kind of rushing
through this but this is something that
you can always finish after the call we
haven't had enough time to really go
through and put numbers on each of the
items or it's kind of disorganized
walking who are writing fast that's fine
um but I'd like for you to look at some
of the ones that you've had um that
you've written and out of those ones see
what your top three are the three that
you have the most seen for and the most
motivation to complete within the next
year if you could pick your top three
what would your top mean what are the
most important goals that you are
excited about and ready to commit now
like you want to stop them today and
they need to be done within the next
year so just go ahead and pick those
three okay and then what I would like
you to do after alcohol is write those
on a separate piece of paper okay or you
couldn't write them and you're
successful and we talked about that
earlier and for each of those three
items write a paragraph of why you are
committed to achieving and they meet and
within your paragraph you need to have
strong enough reason that's why these
I'm going cheated you know this just
like long because it will help me no it
needs to be your driver you know our
goal should be our drivers right so then
write a paragraph to each of those top
three write on a separate piece of paper
why you are committed to achieving them
okay and then well you know another
thing to go setting is as soon as you do
your goals you one of the ways that you
make them really really actionable is by
starting now so after alcohol when we're
done sit with your piece of paper and
pen finish this exercise and figure out
what can you do right now to start you
know so if I decide I
to my weight i want to lose a hundred
pounds what is it that I can do right
this very moment to get started on my
goal I need to call gyms I need to sign
up I need to do this those I can do
today
right so making sure that you are doing
something today and using the momentum
from this webinar from you know the
exercise where you continue to complete
and that's really what now takes you to
the next notch of me starting the
working your dreams is starting now you
know and making that commitment and it
shouldn't be something that okay you put
away maybe you had something to do in
the next hour but this is something that
should be done within the next 24 hours
but if you have time it's the weekend
just go ahead and finish this exercise
and just commit to actually putting some
action around some of the goals that
you've set and some of those top three
what can you do today
you know this phone call that you need
to make it's an email that you need to
say but do something around one or all
three of those goals okay I hope that
exercise was helpful for you and just
kind of you know envisioning a little
bit putting down your goals and working
through this you can put this process to
any type of goals um that you have again
you can do this with your personal goals
you can do this around you know your
financial goals around your career goals
but this is definitely something that
you can repeat but any of the areas of
your life that are important to you okay
so I hope this webinar was helpful for
you a little bit over time but um but
really we've been such a pleasure to you
with all of you I'd like to answer any
last quick questions that you have
before we wind down as anyone have any
other questions
No okay great so we always have some
amazing webinars lined up for some of
our other career coaches we have one
next weekend coming up on February 27th
on culture fit we have another one we
have actually simple in March that are
coming off an intrapreneur mindset
remote work and managing career
transitions you can bookmark udacity.com
slash events to kind of keep updated and
everything that we're doing we're in the
student hub we can come in asking
questions we also have a YouTube channel
where this webinar and have several of
the webinars are posted and this would
only post it as well if you want to come
back to that to kind of you know go
through the goal setting exercise or the
refresher so just you know keep in mind
all the different options you have we
are all happy to support you in your
career path in your journey and really
excited that you are a part of Udacity
so thank you for everyone who joined
we'll be sending a survey to give you
feedback after the call so please give
us you know feedback we're always
looking to improve and I really really
really hope this was helpful for you all
the best with your goals again go out
there do what you need to do in the
world because your work is definitely
needed it's been a pleasure and have a
great weekend ahead